they've been a lot of other times in the
country's history when people looked at
their government looked at the
institutions of government and said you
know what it's not working anymore it's
not right for this moment we've got to
fix things the progressive a century ago
when Teddy Roosevelt was president
people from top to bottom said you know
what we need a different kind of
government and they created stronger
national protections for food safety and
they began conservation and they did all
these things that we now live within the
federal government and they reformed
their politics they passed all kinds of
changes in how politics work including
having senators directly elected by the
people just as one example they've been
many times throughout the country's
history whether it's the Progressive Era
or the civil rights movement of the
1960s or even if you want to look at it
that way the reagan revolution of
cutting back on government where people
looked at their institutions and said
you know what we need a change there's
nothing baked in the cake that says that
we can't have that kind of focus
voting is the heart of the martyrs and
we need to make it so that everyone who
wants to vote can hope everyone wants to
register can register and every vote
that is cast is actually vote that is
counted today our voter registration
system is a remnant of a time when we
set up all these rules to keep former
slaves and Irish immigrants from voting
a hundred years ago there are tens of
millions of people who today aren't on
the voter rolls because they slipped off
when they moved or for all the other
kinds of reasons there's no reason that
we could not have Universal voter
registration in this country we should
just make it a policy that every adult
citizen who's eligible to vote is
registered to vote whether they move
their registered if we did that and it's
easy for the government to do it we
would make it so that the politicians no
longer or spending their time trying to
appeal to the narrowest part of the
electorate but they know that on
Election Day everybody might show up and
that would change politics another thing
we need to do in the area of voting is
make sure that everyone who votes has
their vote counted now there's been a
move toward electronic voting machines
since the year 2000 since the Florida
debacle and that's not necessarily a bad
thing but my group the Brennan Center
convened a task force of top computer
scientists from all over the country
including the federal government to look
at these new electronic machines and ask
well are they really safe could somebody
hack the machines could somebody tilt
the election there's a lot of worrying a
lot of conspiracy theories what are the
facts and what they found out was that
every single one of the electronic
systems is in fact very vulnerable very
vulnerable to hacking to fraud and
terror you know it turns out even
paranoids have enemies when it comes to
electronic voting the good news is there
were all kinds of fixes that could solve
the problem including a paper record and
auditing to make sure that the machines
really counted the vote unfortunately
while many states have made some of the
changes there are no states that have
made all of the changes so there's still
a risk that votes that are
won't be properly counted in this
November and there's still a lot to be
done in that area another set of changes
that would really help democracy has to
do with making sure that elections are
competitive and that the voices of
ordinary citizens are what the
politicians are listening to campaign
finance reform is something people have
been worried about for a long time but
it's really gotten much worse and
there's now an opportunity to make it
much better what I think we ought to do
is move to a system of public financing
of Elections especially for Congress
Congress right now is gridlocked with
special interests members of Congress
have to raise their money from lobbyists
they have to raise their money from the
people who want something out of
government it's one of the reasons very
little happens or certainly very little
that's good if you go down to Washington
DC you want to look for a member of
Congress a lot of the times go down a
block not to the Capitol but to the
campaign committee offices and you'll
see the members of Congress sitting
there in little warrants dialing for
dollars it's not like mr. Smith goes to
Washington it's like Glengarry Glen Ross
I mean it's not what you want your
elected officials to be spending their
time doing and they don't like doing it
either and the there's an opportunity
now to pass reforms that would liberate
them give our elected officials real
independence and give the voters a
bigger voice if you had public financing
of elections as you have in places all
over from Arizona which is quite
conservative to Maine which is liberal
to New York City what you would have is
candidates who qualify would get public
money and there's a way of doing it that
would really boost one of the best
developments one of the best things
that's happened in this election is the
explosion of small contributions mostly
to Obama but to other candidates also
that has democratized fundraising and
made it so that fundraising is a form of
organizing and its small dollars is not
the big bucks we could make it so that
that's how Congress gets elected also
right now that small dollar revolution
is just a rumor in Congress they're
still raising their money overwhelmingly
from
big interests but if you had a system of
matching funds especially something like
if if I give a hundred dollars to a
candidate then the matching fund is four
to one which is the way it is in New
York City's elections then you would
boost ordinary citizens you would make
it so that every every ten dollar
contribution suddenly mattered to the
politicians you would force people
running for office to do some organizing
in their communities and you would
change and greatly diminish the power of
special interest emotion
well when it comes to campaign finance
reform very often people in office don't
think like liberals or conservatives
they don't think like Democrats or
Republicans they think like incumbents
and most incumbents benefit from the
current system is how they got there and
they can always out raise their opponent
but what what is happening that's
exciting is that there is a real
movement among people in Congress to
change the system you've got people in
both houses who've said okay now is the
time to move to public financing John
McCain and Barack Obama are big
supporters of public financing so
there's a real moment here where you
could have I hope bipartisan support for
something that's very real and that
would change America it really would if
you view if people want to have health
care reform if they want to see action
on climate change if they want to see a
fairer tax code whatever it is you want
it's going to be much much easier to do
it if we had a different campaign
finance system if we had universal voter
registration and deep reform of our
democracy another big change that would
make a big difference is in the
electoral college one of the things
that's been very thrilling in this
election is to see all these primaries
in all these states all over the country
places like Indiana and South Dakota and
North Carolina and Guam all these places
that don't have usually a really
competitive election well the bad news
is now that the general election has
started a lot of these places are never
going to see a candidate again because
suddenly everyone's worried about a few
states and and it sometimes feels like
these presidential elections are just
held in Ohio and maybe Florida and if we
had a national popular vote we would not
have the phenomenon which has happened
four times of the guy who comes in
second winning and we wouldn't have the
phenomenon of the candidates campaigning
only in a few states and basically
leaving out the rest of the country now
you know how do you get the end to the
electoral college you need a
constitutional amendment which it can be
done but is very hard but there's
actually a way to bypass the elector
College that doesn't need a
constitutional amendment it's called
national popular vote and it's basically
in agreement among states the state will
pass a law as Illinois and Maryland and
New Jersey and others have done says we
will cast our electoral votes for
whoever wins the national popular vote
as long as enough other states do it
also so that that's who wins and if you
get enough states to do it then you've
ended the Electoral College as a
practical matter even without a
constitutional amendment and if if the
electoral college didn't matter you
would see candidates going to where the
votes are not just those handful of
states again that would be